This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you ever find yourself driving around the Midwest looking for a historic corn mill, or a German culture festival, or a chair factory, there's a chance you might end up in the small town of Jasper, Indiana. Good morning. Driving through what looks to be more or less downtown Jasper, heading over to my first interview. That's reporter Jasper Davidoff reporting from Jasper, Indiana, which admittedly is a little confusing. And you're James? Well, Jasper.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你发现自己开车在美中地区转悠，寻找历史悠久的玉米磨坊、德国文化节或椅子工厂，你很有可能会来到印第安纳州的小镇贾斯珀。早上好。开车穿过看起来差不多是贾斯珀市中心的地方，正前往我的第一次采访。那是记者贾斯珀·达维多夫在印第安纳州贾斯珀的报道，不得不承认这有点让人困惑。你是詹姆斯？嗯，贾斯珀。
I was going to say, with a name like Jasper, you had to come to Jasper. Yeah, well, exactly. I mean, I'm excited to say, with a name like Jasper, you had to come to Jasper. Yeah, well exactly. I mean, I'm excited to be here. I was in Jasper, the place, this past fall because I wanted to talk with a guy named Jim Tin. My name is Jim Tin. With my wife Pat, Jasper is our home. I was born here.
我正想说，名字叫贾斯珀，你就得来贾斯珀。是的，没错。我的意思是，我很高兴能来到这里。去年秋天我去了贾斯珀这个地方，因为我想采访一个叫吉姆·廷的人。我叫吉姆·廷。我和妻子帕特，贾斯珀是我们的家。我出生在这里。
Jim's dad, Herb Tin, was the mayor of Jasper back in the 1940s and 50s. And when Jim was about seven years old, the town did something kind of radical, something that no other city had done before. They made garbage illegal. As of August 1st, 1950, they drew a bright line and said, if you were in the city, they would no longer collect any garbage Although the city was still collecting stuff like plastics soup cans a lot of what you might recycle today It was no longer picking up organic waste or what the city called the garbage That's stuff like yard trimmings or the yucky things that people typically throw out like chicken bones rotten fruit or the yucky things that people typically throw out, like chicken bones, rotten fruit, eggshells.
吉姆的父亲赫伯·廷在20世纪40年代和50年代曾是贾斯珀的市长。当吉姆大约七岁时，这个小镇做了一件相当激进的事情，一件其他城市从未做过的事情。他们宣布垃圾非法。从1950年8月1日起，他们划定了一条明确的界线，并表示，如果你在城里，他们将不再收集任何垃圾。虽然城市仍在收集塑料、汤罐头等东西，也就是今天你可能会回收的很多东西，但它不再收集有机废物，或者城市所称的“垃圾”。那是指庭院修剪物，或者人们通常扔掉的恶心东西，比如鸡骨头、烂水果、蛋壳。
And this sanitation vanishing act was made possible by a relatively new appliance, one that would soon make its way into kitchens across the country. The garbage disposer. The garbage disposer is that little grinding machine at the bottom of a lot of kitchen sinks. Most people call it the disposal with an AL or the in-sink-er-ator or even the gar-ber-ator,
这种卫生方面的“消失魔术”之所以成为可能，是因为一种相对较新的电器，一种很快就会进入全国各地厨房的电器。食物垃圾处理器。食物垃圾处理器就是许多厨房水槽底部那个小小的研磨机。大多数人称之为“disposal”（带AL结尾）或者“in-sink-er-ator”，甚至叫“gar-ber-ator”。
but to keep things simple and avoid brand names, we're going to use the generic disposer with an ER. I know it sounds a little weird. If you live in the United States, you either have a garbage disposer in your sink, or you at least have a friend or relative with one in theirs. According to the 2013 American Housing Survey, nearly half of all households have a disposer.
但为了简单起见，避免使用品牌名称，我们将使用通用的“disposer”（带ER结尾）。我知道这听起来有点奇怪。如果你住在美国，你的水槽里要么有一个食物垃圾处理器，要么你至少有一个朋友或亲戚的水槽里有。根据2013年的美国住房调查，近一半的家庭拥有处理器。
In other countries, these machines aren't nearly as common. And until recently, the most I ever really thought about a disposer was as a kid, when my mom got mad at me for throwing cherry-fit stone at ours. But over the last couple months, I've become a little obsessed with the monster under our sinks, and how despite the awful sounds it makes, the disposer quietly managed to become a staple of the American kitchen, and changed the way we think about our food waste.
在其他国家，这些机器并不那么普遍。直到最近，我真正想到处理器的时候，还是小时候，当时我妈因为我把樱桃核扔进我们的处理器里而对我发火。但在过去几个月里，我开始对我们水槽下的这个“怪物”有点着迷，尽管它发出的声音很可怕，但处理器还是悄悄地成为了美式厨房的主食，并改变了我们对食物垃圾的看法。
The story of the garbage disposer starts long before Jasper Indiana's experiment. It even starts, you could say, before the invention of garbage. It used to be that people didn't have much garbage. They didn't create much garbage. If something broke, you would take it back to the person who made it to get it fixed. Or there would be people who specialized in repairs who would fix things. Susan Strasser is a historian who studies consumerism, domesticity, and yes, garbage. She says that up until the late 1800s, people were just much less wasteful.
食物垃圾处理器的故事早在印第安纳州贾斯珀的实验之前就开始了。甚至可以说，它在“垃圾”这个概念发明之前就开始了。过去，人们并没有多少垃圾。他们制造的垃圾不多。如果东西坏了，你会把它带回制造它的人那里去修理。或者会有专门从事修理的人来修理东西。苏珊·斯特拉瑟是一位研究消费主义、家庭生活以及垃圾的历史学家。她说，直到19世纪末，人们浪费的情况要少得多。
People ate food scraps. If you read books about how to run your household, people are advised to, when they clear the table, save food. And the expectation was that good food would be eaten by people. Food scraps weren't thought of as a burden, but as an opportunity, a way to save for another meal or to repurpose into candles and soap. The idea of wasting food was really anathema to most people. Food that wasn't quite good enough for the people could be fed to animals. There were pets, dogs and cats, but also many, many people kept chickens even in urban and suburban areas
人们会吃掉食物残渣。如果你读过关于如何经营家庭的书，人们会被建议在清理餐桌时保存食物。当时的期望是，好的食物会被人吃掉。食物残渣不被视为负担，而是一个机会，一种为下一顿饭节省开支或将其改造成蜡烛和肥皂的方法。浪费食物的想法对大多数人来说简直是深恶痛绝。不太适合人吃的食物可以喂给动物。当时有宠物，猫和狗，但也有很多人，即使在城市和郊区，也会养鸡。
and chickens will eat pretty much anything and give you eggs in return. But at the turn of the century, the commercialization of food made more of it available at a cheaper price and that abundance made it easier for people to throw out their scraps. Around the same time, lots of people were moving from the countryside into U.S. cities. And all that food waste was literally piling up on the street, creating not only a smelly problem but a public health one. Back then, many still believed that diseases like cholera were spreading through noxious odors, including those emanating from piles of garbage.
鸡几乎什么都吃，并会给你下蛋作为回报。但在世纪之交，食品的商业化使得更多食品以更便宜的价格供应，这种充裕使得人们更容易扔掉残渣。大约在同一时间，许多人从农村搬到了美国城市。所有这些食物垃圾真的堆积在街上，不仅造成了气味问题，还造成了公共卫生问题。那时，许多人仍然相信霍乱等疾病是通过恶臭传播的，包括那些从垃圾堆中散发出来的气味。
Garbage being a pretty technical term at the time that really did refer to perishable waste as opposed to rubbish that might have been less perishable products that were being thrown away. Anna Zeta is a food historian at Virginia Tech. She says that unlike the catch-all definition garbage has today, it used to refer specifically to organic waste, which in case you haven't already caught on, is how I'm going to keep using garbage for the rest of this story. Around the country, there wasn't much of an appetite by federal and state governments to
“垃圾”（Garbage）在当时是一个相当专业术语，确实是指易腐烂的废物，而不是指那些可能不太易腐烂的被扔掉的产品，即“垃圾”（rubbish）。安娜·泽塔是弗吉尼亚理工大学的食品历史学家。她说，与今天“垃圾”这个包罗万象的定义不同，它过去专门指有机废物，顺便说一下，如果你还没听出来，这就是我在这个故事的其余部分将如何使用“垃圾”这个词的方式。在全国范围内，联邦和州政府并没有多大兴趣去
take on the growing garbage problem. Instead, the job of waste collection fell to individual cities and towns. And so municipal regulations began to be developed in quite scattershot ways, very piecemeal in different localities to try to address what was happening with this garbage. Some municipalities started collection services to haul their waste to a dump. Others demanded citizens split up their kitchen refuse from their other waste. The discarded food would get sent to local farmers, who used it as feed for their hogs. But there too a lot of problems for health emerged in that a lot of so-called uncooked garbage could carry various kinds of pathogens that caused widespread disease in the pigs themselves,
解决日益严重的垃圾问题。相反，废物收集的工作落在了各个城市和城镇身上。因此，市政法规开始以相当零散的方式制定，在不同地区非常零碎地试图解决垃圾问题。一些城市开始提供收集服务，将废物运往垃圾填埋场。另一些城市则要求市民将厨房垃圾与其他废物分开。丢弃的食物会被送到当地农民那里，他们将其用作猪饲料。但那里也出现了许多健康问题，因为许多所谓的“未煮熟的垃圾”可能携带各种病原体，导致猪群本身爆发广泛的疾病，
some of which was feared would carry over into any humans who were eating the meat that came from the pigs. By the early 1920s, these haphazard systems of garbage collection were struggling to keep up with 20th century consumerism. Cities and towns were burning garbage, even throwing it in their local river. And so into this maelstrom of
其中一些令人担心会传染给食用这些猪肉的人类。到了20世纪20年代初，这些杂乱无章的垃圾收集系统难以跟上20世纪的消费主义步伐。城市和城镇在焚烧垃圾，甚至将其扔进当地的河流中。于是，在这场混乱的
detritus stepped the engineers at the General Electric Company. A few communities had started grinding up their garbage in these massive machines and washing it down into their local sewers. GE took this totally new concept, mixing sewage with food waste, and tried to expand on it. If you could use a large-scale grinder to get rid of the town's garbage, could you build small household ones to eliminate garbage at the source? So in 1930, two GE representatives traveled to Schenectady, New York, to visit a sanitary engineer named Morris Cohn. He agreed to help GE conduct their research and even started experimenting in his own home,
废弃物中，通用电气公司的工程师们登场了。一些社区已经开始用这些大型机器研磨垃圾，并将其冲入当地的下水道。通用电气采用了这个全新的概念，将污水与食物垃圾混合，并试图对其进行扩展。如果你能用大型研磨机处理城镇的垃圾，能不能制造小型家用研磨机来从源头上消除垃圾呢？因此，1930年，两名通用电气代表前往纽约州斯克内克塔迪，拜访了一位名叫莫里斯·科恩的卫生工程师。他同意帮助通用电气进行研究，甚至开始在自己家里进行实验，
pulverizing food in a meat grinder and flushing the results down the toilet. He agreed to help GE conduct their research and even started experimenting in his own home, pulverizing food in a meat grinder and flushing the results down the toilet. And before long, all that flushing yielded a result. They called it the disposal. And here's how coarse particles like corn cobs get the works inside a general electric disposal. cobs get the works inside a general electric disposal. In almost less time than it takes to tell you about it, they'll be whittled down to corn kernel size or smaller and given a one-way ticket down the drain." By the late 30s, people started getting very excited about garbage disposers. Scientific American predicted that the disposer would make the garbage can obsolete.
把食物放在绞肉机里粉碎，然后把结果冲进马桶。他同意帮助通用电气进行研究，甚至开始在自己家里进行实验，把食物放在绞肉机里粉碎，然后把结果冲进马桶。不久之后，所有的冲洗都产生了结果。他们称之为“disposal”。这就是像玉米芯这样的粗颗粒在通用电气处理器内部的处理过程。在讲述它的时间里，它们就会被磨成玉米粒大小或更小，并被送入下水道。到30年代末，人们开始对食物垃圾处理器感到非常兴奋。《科学美国人》预测，处理器将使垃圾桶过时。
An article in House and Garden magazine introduced readers to new garbage tech like rubber plate scrapers and waxed garbage pail liners, but its highest praise was for the disposer. You're not going to have rats. You're not going to have the smelly stuff in your kitchen. You're not going to have the problems that come with food waste anymore because you're going to wash it down the drain. Pete Slauson Even with all this hype, companies like GE still didn't have what they really wanted, a test site. A place to prove that the disposer wasn't just a benefit for an individual household, but a bona fide improvement for an entire community. Jasper would soon change all that.
《家居与花园》杂志的一篇文章向读者介绍了新的垃圾技术，如橡胶盘刮板和打蜡的垃圾桶衬垫，但它最高的赞誉是给处理器的。你不会有老鼠。你的厨房里不会有难闻的东西。你不会再有食物垃圾带来的问题，因为你会把它们冲进下水道。皮特·斯劳森。即使有所有这些炒作，像通用电气这样的公司仍然没有他们真正想要的东西：一个测试点。一个证明处理器不仅对个人家庭有益，而且对整个社区都是真正改善的地方。贾斯珀很快就会改变这一切。
I would? Sorry, I wasn't talking about you. Here's what I meant. Jasper, Indiana would soon change all that. Dad was an original thinker. He was a creative person and a good problem solver. And he was very health conscious, very civic minded. That's Jim Tinigan.
我会吗？抱歉，我不是在说你。我是这个意思。印第安纳州贾斯珀很快就会改变这一切。爸爸是一个有独创性的人。他是一个有创造力的人，也是一个很好的问题解决者。他非常有健康意识，非常有公民意识。那是吉姆·廷。
His dad was the mayor of Jasper back in the 40s and 50s. At the time, Jasper was struggling with a ton of public health problems. Rats and flies were a common nuisance in town. There was an outbreak of swine cholera in 1947, which traced back to the garbage farmers had fed the pigs. And this was followed quickly by the polio epidemic, which at the time locals felt might be related
他的父亲在40年代和50年代是贾斯珀的市长。当时，贾斯珀正面临着大量的公共卫生问题。老鼠和苍蝇是镇上常见的麻烦。1947年爆发了猪霍乱，追溯到农民喂猪的垃圾。紧随其后的是小儿麻痹症流行，当时当地人认为这可能与
to the flies buzzing around open troughs of garbage. And so one day Mayor Tin was walking with his wife in nearby Evansville when he stumbled on a solution to the town's problems. He saw a disposal in the Sears robot display window. The sign in the window read, say goodbye to your garbage can. And in that moment, Mayor Tin saw an opportunity
在露天垃圾槽周围嗡嗡作响的苍蝇有关。所以有一天，廷市长和他的妻子在附近的埃文斯维尔散步时，偶然发现了解决城镇问题的办法。他在西尔斯机器人展示窗里看到了一个处理器。窗户上的标牌写着：告别你的垃圾桶。那一刻，廷市长看到了一个机会，
to change everything. A week later, the mayor bought his very own garbage disposer. The appliance and the installation ran him about $125 or about $1,500 today. And like the highly technical, sophisticated sanitary engineers that came before him, the mayor just started chucking things down his disposer
去改变一切。一周后，市长买了他自己的食物垃圾处理器。电器和安装费用大约是125美元，相当于今天的1500美元左右。像他之前的那些技术高超、老练的卫生工程师一样，市长开始把东西扔进他的处理器里，
to test the results. We put a disposal in our house, I believe it was in 48. Dad felt we had to lead and show the way, and so we put one in just to be able to show people that it worked. TITLE Mayor Tin liked what he saw and started putting together what would come to be known as the Jasper Plan. The mayor envisioned a Jasper where every home had a disposer, where the city helped residents buy a disposer, where the disposer solved Jasper's garbage problem once and for all.
来测试结果。我相信我们在48年就在家里装了一个处理器。爸爸觉得我们必须带头并指明方向，所以我们装了一个，只是为了向人们展示它确实有效。标题：廷市长喜欢他所看到的，并开始制定后来被称为“贾斯珀计划”的内容。市长设想了一个贾斯珀，每个家庭都有一个处理器，城市帮助居民购买处理器，处理器一劳永逸地解决了贾斯珀的垃圾问题。
No other city in the country had ever tried to systematically install disposers, partly because the household disposer was still relatively new and actually pretty expensive. But also partly because nobody knew what would happen after this much food made its way down the drain. You know, this is something that had to be worked out between the companies making garbage disposers and the municipal engineers. And the reason was that the municipal engineers were not sure that the sewers could handle the products of the garbage disposer.
全国没有其他城市尝试过系统地安装处理器，部分原因是家用处理器当时还相对较新，而且实际上相当昂贵。但部分原因也是因为没人知道在这么多食物进入下水道后会发生什么。你知道，这是必须在制造食物垃圾处理器的公司和市政工程师之间解决的问题。原因是市政工程师不确定下水道是否能处理食物垃圾处理器的产物。
Sanitary engineers were often split. Some towns were confident that their sewers could handle ground up garbage. But engineers in older, denser areas like Philadelphia and Boston had reservations. There was a fear that the disposer would clog pipes and lead to expensive repairs. And so some places, including New York City,
卫生工程师们往往意见不一。一些城镇确信他们的下水道可以处理研磨后的垃圾。但费城和波士顿等较老、较密集地区的工程师则有保留意见。人们担心处理器会堵塞管道并导致昂贵的维修费用。因此，一些地方，包括纽约市，
actually moved to ban these newfangled machines. But Jasper was willing to try and prove them wrong. The city council was confident their disposer plan would work because they were already planning to build a new wastewater treatment plant. They could just amend those plans and upgrade Jasper's sewers to accommodate
实际上采取了禁止这些新奇机器的措施。但贾斯珀愿意尝试并证明他们是错的。市议会确信他们的处理器计划会奏效，因为他们已经在计划建造一个新的污水处理厂。他们可以修改这些计划，升级贾斯珀的下水道以适应
for all this new incoming garbage. And civic leaders weren't the only ones backing the Jasper's sewers to accommodate for all this new incoming garbage. And civic leaders weren't the only ones backing the Jasper plan. After the son of a local newspaper editor contracted polio, he began using the Du Bois County Herald to praise Jasper's garbage disposer idea. He hailed it as quote, a boon to city sanitation, the results of which would be quote, the beginning of a great national movement. While it may seem silly to us now to think that a garbage disposer might help eradicate polio, at the time, people were understandably scared.
所有这些新进入的垃圾。而且公民领袖并不是唯一支持贾斯珀计划的人。在当地一家报纸编辑的儿子感染小儿麻痹症后，他开始利用《杜波依斯县先驱报》来赞扬贾斯珀的食物垃圾处理器理念。他称其为“城市卫生的福音”，其结果将是“一场伟大的全国性运动的开始”。虽然现在认为食物垃圾处理器可能有助于根除小儿麻痹症对我们来说似乎很愚蠢，但在当时，人们理所当然地感到害怕。
It wasn't yet common knowledge that the disease mainly spreads from person to person. Nevertheless, the Jasper Plan was a chance for the city to do something big, to become the only place in the country to put an end to garbage. The city council voted unanimously to do it. The city council, the mayor, and the head of the sanitation,
当时人们还不知道这种疾病主要是人与人之间传播的。尽管如此，贾斯珀计划是该市做大事的一个机会，成为全国唯一一个终结垃圾的地方。市议会一致投票通过了该计划。市议会、市长和卫生部门负责人，
they all volunteered to put disposals in their homes. And I can remember the day when Dad took me to the town square when a semi-truck pulled up and had a little over a thousand garbage disposals on it. Here's the thing about the Jasper Plan. It was billed as an option for residents, but in practice it was effectively a mandate. The city was going to refuse to pick up any trash with organic waste in it and ban garbage cans altogether. So people would more or less have to buy a disposer. The city helped finance them and even got
他们都自愿在家里安装了处理器。我记得爸爸带我去镇广场的那一天，一辆半挂卡车停了下来，上面有1000多个食物垃圾处理器。关于贾斯珀计划，事情是这样的：它被宣传为居民的一种选择，但实际上它基本上是一项强制令。城市将拒绝收集任何含有有机废物的垃圾，并完全禁止垃圾桶。所以人们或多或少必须购买一个处理器。城市帮助资助它们，甚至给
residents a discount, but each disposer still sold for $75 or close to $1,000 today. Jim Tinn recalls this being a slightly dangerous time to be the mayor's kid. Once in a while coming home from school, some kids would confront us. Sometimes there was punches thrown or shoving here and there. I suppose that came from the conversation at their dinner table, maybe perhaps on the cost,
居民提供了折扣，但每个处理器仍然售价75美元，相当于今天的近1000美元。吉姆·廷回忆说，作为市长的孩子，这是一段有点危险的时期。偶尔放学回家，一些孩子会与我们对峙。有时会有拳头相向或推搡。我想这源于他们餐桌上的谈话，也许是因为成本，
perhaps on the fact that they were kind of being forced. Still by February, 1950, enough people had opted in that the city was ready to execute the final piece of the plan, the garbage ban. And with that, the Tin Family became a media sensation. Just about every magazine, every major newspaper came to our house. Then Life magazine, Look magazine were big magazines back then. Posts, they all came to photograph my mother and my sister, usually putting garbage down to disposal.
也许是因为他们被强迫的事实。尽管如此，到1950年2月，已经有足够多的人选择加入，城市准备执行计划的最后一部分：垃圾禁令。随之，廷一家成了媒体轰动人物。几乎每一本杂志、每一家主要报纸都来到我们家。《生活》杂志、《Look》杂志在当时都是大杂志。《邮报》，他们都来拍摄我母亲和我姐姐，通常是把垃圾放进处理器里。
One of them, GE touted the durability of their disposal. And to prove that, they would put a Coke bottle down there. And this is when Coke bottles were heavy glass Coke bottles. Just quick PSA, don't ever do this, like ever. And they'd put it down there and grind it up, grind it to show that the spoles all was very durable and there was nothing you could do to harm it. With the Jasper Plan in effect, nearly 95% of residents had a garbage disposer installed.
其中一家，通用电气吹捧其处理器的耐用性。为了证明这一点，他们会把一个可乐瓶放进去。这是在可乐瓶还是重玻璃瓶的时候。快速公益广告：千万别这么做，永远别。他们会把它放进去并研磨，研磨以显示处理器非常耐用，没有什么能伤害它。随着贾斯珀计划的实施，近95%的居民安装了食物垃圾处理器。
And because of all the press coverage, Mayor Tin became a sort of oracle for government officials looking to solve their garbage problems. Cities in Michigan and Illinois started hatching their own versions of a Jasper plan. And eventually, some 60 communities tried to go garbage-free. I remember dad getting letters, phone calls from around the world, other mayors wanting to know, how did you do it, does it work, all of that. And that's the question a lot of people were asking. Public health officials, newspapers, everyone wanted to know what happened in the town that
由于所有的媒体报道，廷市长成了政府官员寻求解决垃圾问题的某种先知。密歇根州和伊利诺伊州的城市开始酝酿他们自己的贾斯珀计划版本。最终，大约60个社区尝试实现“无垃圾”。我记得爸爸收到来自世界各地的信件和电话，其他市长想知道：你是怎么做到的？它有效吗？等等。这就是许多人问的问题。公共卫生官员、报纸，每个人都想知道那个
tried to make garbage disappear. After the break, the results of the Jasper Plan and what garbage disposers do for us today. The question of whether the Jasper plan worked depends on who you ask, and that's because different people had different ideas of success. So for example, if you ask the folks over at General Electric, they definitely thought the plan worked. This is part of a larger advertising blitz GE undertook in 1970 to mark Jasper's 20th anniversary going garbage-free. They ran ads about the town in Time, Newsweek, and The New Yorker that fall. For 20 years now, General Electric has been
试图让垃圾消失的城镇发生了什么。休息后，贾斯珀计划的结果以及食物垃圾处理器今天为我们做了什么。贾斯珀计划是否奏效的问题取决于你问谁，这是因为不同的人对成功有不同的想法。例如，如果你问通用电气的人，他们肯定认为计划奏效了。这是通用电气在1970年为纪念贾斯珀实现“无垃圾”20周年而进行的大规模广告宣传的一部分。那年秋天，他们在《时代》、《新闻周刊》和《纽约客》上刊登了关于该镇的广告。20年来，通用电气一直在
grinding up Jasper's garbage and starving out Jasper's flies. Men helping man. General Electric. The city itself, however, wasn't quite as confident as GE on the fly issue. Herb Tinn, who was by then the former mayor, told a New York Times reporter in 1974, Let's get it straight right now, there are flies in Jasper. There were still flies, you know, just not as many. But that's the thing that kind of caught on in the press. No flies in the city of Jasper. But the fly issue was mostly a proxy for a much more ambitious goal of the Jasper plan, to help stamp out diseases like polio and cholera.
研磨贾斯珀的垃圾，饿死贾斯珀的苍蝇。人助人。通用电气。然而，城市本身在苍蝇问题上并不像通用电气那样自信。赫伯·廷，当时已经是前市长，在1974年告诉《纽约时报》记者：“现在就把话说清楚，贾斯珀有苍蝇。”你知道，仍然有苍蝇，只是没那么多。但这就是媒体上流传的东西：贾斯珀市没有苍蝇。但苍蝇问题主要是贾斯珀计划一个更宏大目标的代理，即帮助根除小儿麻痹症和霍乱等疾病。
And you can probably guess the garbage disposer didn't do that either. What really helped keep Jasper's residents safe from getting sick were things like the polio vaccine and the construction of its wastewater treatment plant. Here's Ana Zeta again. You know, disease and poor health comes from so many factors that are beyond simply open garbage bins and alleyways that it's hard to imagine how the disposal could have been a decisive factor. And so I do think some of these larger campaigns, like the one in Jasper, built on and profited
你可能猜到了，食物垃圾处理器也没有做到这一点。真正有助于保护贾斯珀居民免受疾病侵害的是小儿麻痹症疫苗和污水处理厂的建设等因素。再次请安娜·泽塔来说。你知道，疾病和健康状况不佳源于许多因素，而不仅仅是露天的垃圾桶和巷道，所以很难想象处理器怎么会成为决定性因素。所以我确实认为其中一些更大的运动，比如贾斯珀的那个，建立在并利用了
from concerns like the polio epidemic and these individual fears that consumers had about how rising levels of waste might contribute to them getting sick or their family members getting sick or their family members getting sick. In Jasper and around the country, the garbage disposer worked its way into post-war housing under the guise of public health and the elimination of garbage. But even if companies like GE couldn't deliver on those promises, they were able to keep selling people on something else. Its convenience.
像小儿麻痹症流行这样的担忧，以及消费者对日益增长的废物水平可能导致他们或其家人患病的个人恐惧。在贾斯珀和全国各地，食物垃圾处理器以公共卫生和消除垃圾为幌子进入了战后住房。但即使像通用电气这样的公司无法兑现这些承诺，他们也能够继续向人们推销别的东西：它的便利性。
When I walked through the Du Bois County Museum with Arthur Nordhoff, the local historian, that simplicity is exactly what he remembered. So this says, this ad says ask the teenagers how did they work out ask the teenagers who never had to take out the garbage. So was that you? Yeah sure because I wouldn't have to take it out. And I lived in a regular house down by the hospital. And so once a week, I'd have to take the garbage out to the garbage pail. But not anymore.
当我与当地历史学家亚瑟·诺德霍夫一起走过杜波依斯县博物馆时，那种简单正是他所记得的。所以这上面写着，这则广告说：问问青少年他们是怎么做到的，问问那些从来不用倒垃圾的青少年。所以那是你吗？是的，当然，因为我不用去倒垃圾。我住在医院旁边的一栋普通房子里。所以每周一次，我得把垃圾拿到垃圾桶里。但现在不用了。
Not anymore. Not anymore. These days, companies selling garbage disposers emphasize something else, too, that the appliance doesn't only make cleaning up easier, but it's actually a sustainable solution for the problem of kitchen waste. Yeah, I think that people have been led to believe
不用了。不用了。如今，销售食物垃圾处理器的公司也强调了别的东西，即该电器不仅使清理工作更容易，而且实际上是解决厨房垃圾问题的可持续方案。是的，我认为人们被引导相信
that sending your food waste down the drain is beneficial and is much better than landfilling it. And sadly, the truth is that it's not. Claudia Fabiano works on the sustainable management of food at the EPA. Last October, her team put out a report that firmly places the agency in the anti-disposer camp. Sending food down the drain, it ranks equally with landfilling and incineration of food.
把食物垃圾冲进下水道是有益的，比填埋要好得多。可悲的是，事实并非如此。克劳迪娅·法比亚诺在环保署从事食品的可持续管理工作。去年10月，她的团队发布了一份报告，坚定地将该机构置于“反处理器”阵营。把食物冲进下水道，其排名与食物的填埋和焚烧相当。
And those are really to be avoided if you can. There are a couple reasons why the EPA would love if you didn't scrape your dinner plate into your sink. But what it really boils down to is that a lot of energy is wasted when food goes through the wastewater system. And all that ground-up food emits a ton of methane. In addition to that methane being released in the sewers, sending food down the drain also introduces more fats, oils, and greases to the sewer systems, which can cause blockages and increase maintenance costs.
如果可以的话，这些确实应该避免。环保署希望你不要把餐盘里的残渣刮进水槽，有几个原因。但归根结底，当食物通过污水系统时，会浪费大量能源。所有这些研磨后的食物会排放大量的甲烷。除了在下水道中释放甲烷外，把食物冲进下水道还会向污水系统引入更多的脂肪、油和油脂，这会导致堵塞并增加维护成本。
And food waste in the sewer system can also cause pipe corrosion. To date, there's still a real fear about the effects of garbage disposers. Some countries have banned them and others try to discourage their use. Even in New York City, which repealed its ban in the 1990s, you still almost never come across a disposer. While the city's sanitary engineers say that the sewers could handle the ground-up waste, it's the pipes in the old buildings that people worry about. But despite a lot of these drawbacks, the disposer has managed to persist in a lot of American homes, especially in Jasper.
污水系统中的食物垃圾也会导致管道腐蚀。迄今为止，人们仍然对食物垃圾处理器的影响感到真正的恐惧。一些国家已经禁止了它们，另一些国家则试图劝阻使用它们。即使在纽约市，虽然在90年代废除了禁令，但你几乎从未见过处理器。虽然该市的卫生工程师表示下水道可以处理研磨后的废物，但人们担心的是老建筑里的管道。但尽管有许多这些缺点，处理器还是设法在许多美国家庭中坚持了下来，特别是在贾斯珀。
And it's still a requirement for people to put garbage disposals in until there are any new homes being built or even existing homes, all of them have garbage disposals. This is Bud Hauersberger, Jasper's current general manager of utilities. Bud told me that Jasper's garbage disposer ordinance is still technically on the books to this day. But at some point, the city's resolve on the whole garbage man piece of it just kind of fizzled. Are you allowed to throw away garbage or food waste these days?
而且人们仍然被要求安装食物垃圾处理器，直到有任何新建房屋，甚至是现有房屋，它们都有食物垃圾处理器。这是巴德·豪尔斯伯格，贾斯珀现任公用事业总经理。巴德告诉我，贾斯珀的食物垃圾处理器条例在今天仍然在册。但在某个时候，城市在整个“垃圾人”问题上的决心就有点消退了。你现在被允许扔掉垃圾或食物残渣吗？
Yes, I don't think they inspect the trash bags. Basically, there's some weight limits on how much a trash bag, full trash bag, could weigh in the size of the trash bags. Basically, there's some weight limits on how much a trash bag, full trash bag, could weigh and the size of the trash bag. But I don't think anybody inspects what's in there. Jasper, like almost every other place in the country, hasn't been able to escape the realities of garbage. But over the years, they built a system
是的，我不认为他们会检查垃圾袋。基本上，垃圾袋的重量有限制，装满的垃圾袋有多重，以及垃圾袋的大小。基本上，垃圾袋的重量有限制，装满的垃圾袋有多重，以及垃圾袋的大小。但我不认为有人会检查里面有什么。贾斯珀，就像全国几乎所有其他地方一样，没能逃脱垃圾的现实。但多年来，他们建立了一个
that works well enough for them and all their disposers. On a walk through Jasper's wastewater facility, Bud showed me two of the ways they try to recapture some of the energy that's lost when food goes down the drain. A couple things I didn't talk about in the office were the anaerobic digester, that kind of dome structure over there. We collect the methane gas off of the waste and we use that to co-generate electricity. Plus we also use- And as we walked through all the tanks and machines,
对他们和他们所有的处理器来说足够有效的系统。在参观贾斯珀污水处理设施时，巴德向我展示了他们试图回收食物进入下水道时损失的部分能源的两种方法。我在办公室里没谈到的几件事是厌氧消化器，那边那个圆顶结构。我们从废物中收集甲烷气体，并用它来共同发电。此外，我们还使用——当我们走过所有的水箱和机器时，
Bud pointed out where Jasper's wastewater gets filtered and processed. And yeah, it's not the prettiest sight, but it was cool to see this up close. Once the remnants of Jasper's organic waste are treated and separated from the water, it creates this almost compost-like mixture. So I'm seeing like kind of like a muddy green like, but then it sort of basically kind of just looks like soil at the end or? Yeah, that's right. Yeah. and there's a, what'd you say?
巴德指出了贾斯珀的污水被过滤和处理的地方。是的，这不是最漂亮的景象，但近距离观察很酷。一旦贾斯珀有机废物的残余物被处理并与水分离，它就会产生这种几乎像堆肥一样的混合物。所以我看到的是一种泥泞的绿色，但最后它看起来基本上就像土壤？是的，没错。是的。还有，你说什么？
Good, dark soil. I mean, it's got a lot of nutrients in that soil. Oh, so that's gonna be good for when you- In sanitary parlance, this slurry of treated sewage and food waste is known as biosolids. But the more general term is sludge, which is also way more fun to say. And in a lot of places, sludge gets thrown
好的，深色土壤。我的意思是，那土壤里有很多营养物质。哦，所以当你……的时候那会很有用。在卫生术语中，这种处理过的污水和食物垃圾的浆液被称为“生物固体”。但更通用的术语是“污泥”，说起来也更有趣。在很多地方，污泥被扔进
into the local landfill, same as if you were throwing your apple core in the garbage can. In Jasper, though, they do something different. They use it as fertilizer. They get it for free, basically. The farmers do, and it kind of helps them, so they don't have to put as much nitrogen and other kind of chemicals on the
当地的垃圾填埋场，就像你把苹果核扔进垃圾桶一样。但在贾斯珀，他们做的事情不同。他们把它用作肥料。他们基本上是免费得到的。农民们这样做，这在某种程度上对他们有帮助，所以他们不必在田里施用那么多的氮和其他化学物质，
field where they can use something like this, which is a little more natural. Even though that sounds great, researchers worry that applying sludge back onto farmland could introduce pollutants into the groundwater. At least one state, Maine, has actually banned the practice. The EPA also says that while anaerobic digesters are a good source of renewable energy, using them doesn't cancel out all the methane that's released in the sewers. Regardless, all of this sort of obfuscates a larger point. We spend a lot of time thinking about how to build machines or find new ways of dealing
而可以使用像这样的东西，它更自然一些。尽管这听起来不错，但研究人员担心将污泥重新施用到农田可能会将污染物引入地下水。至少有一个州，缅因州，实际上已经禁止了这种做法。环保署还表示，虽然厌氧消化器是可再生能源的良好来源，但使用它们并不能抵消下水道中释放的所有甲烷。无论如何，所有这些都在某种程度上掩盖了一个更大的观点。我们花了很多时间思考如何制造机器或寻找处理我们购买的东西的残余物的新方法。
with the remains of what we buy. But there's a more effective way to keep garbage off the streets, out of the sewers, and out of the landfill. It's figuring out ways to avoid creating food waste in the first place. You know, we have this desire to be good providers, right? We want to make sure that we always have enough food on hand for us, for our kids, for the unexpected family that drops by and now all of a sudden I need to put food out for them too. And I think being a good provider means make enough for everybody, but not so much that you end up throwing so much in the trash. But the concept of creating less food waste in the first place is hard.
但有一种更有效的方法可以让垃圾远离街道、下水道和垃圾填埋场。那就是想办法从一开始就避免产生食物垃圾。你知道，我们有一种成为好供应者的愿望，对吧？我们想确保我们手头总是有足够的食物供我们自己、我们的孩子、不期而至的家人使用，现在突然之间我也需要为他们准备食物。我认为成为一个好的供应者意味着为每个人准备足够的食物，但不要多到最后扔掉那么多垃圾。但从一开始就减少食物垃圾的概念很难。
It requires all of us to take a second and think about what's going to happen to our garbage next. Which isn't as easy as flipping a switch and watching it all disappear down the drain. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Jasper Davidoff and edited by Jason De Leon, with additional production by Jacob Maldonado Medina. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Royale. Fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is the
它需要我们每个人花点时间思考我们的垃圾接下来会发生什么。这并不像按下开关看着它全部消失在下水道里那么容易。《99%隐形》本周由贾斯珀·达维多夫报道，杰森·德·莱昂编辑，雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳参与制作。马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和声音设计。音乐由斯旺·罗亚尔创作。格雷厄姆·海沙负责事实核查。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是
senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lodge Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Sarah Bake, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Martin Molossi, Ed Hollenden, Lily Geismar, Amy Vedra, and Sue Ellen Hoy, whose research on Jasper was a great resource for this episode. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north
高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、洛奇·马登、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、莎拉·贝克、尼娜·波图克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本周特别感谢马丁·莫洛西、埃德·霍伦登、莉莉·盖斯玛、艾米·维德拉和苏·艾伦·霍伊，他们对贾斯珀的研究是本集的重要资源。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区
in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. Home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the Roots are Oakland first. Always. Congrats on winning your home over here, guys. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our own Discord server. There's over 2,500 people there talking about the power broker, and architecture, and movies,
的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。奥克兰根足球俱乐部的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根队永远是奥克兰的。永远。恭喜你们赢得了主场，伙计们。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有超过2500人在讨论《权力掮客》、建筑、电影、
and reality TV shows, and it's a really nice place to hang out. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和真人秀节目，这是一个非常好的消磨时间的地方。在99PI.org上有一个链接，以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。